PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
In this session, we're going to
tackle initial value problem y
dot plus t*y equals to t.
And this initial
value problem is
going to be subject to the
initial condition, y of 0
equals to 3.
We are going to use the
method of integration factor.
And what I want you to use
is both definite integrals
and indefinite integrals.
So why don't you
take a few minutes
to think about the problem?
And we will be right back.
Welcome back.
So I hope that you worked out
the first part of the problem.
So what are we going to
do to solve this ODE?
First, we need to review what
is the method of integrating
factor.
So when we use the
integrating factor,
basically, we're
trying to write down
our ODE in a different form
by introducing a function u.
And the goal is to find
the function u such
that we can rewrite
this left-hand side
as the derivative of
the product y dot u.
So in this case, if we're
looking at identifying
the function u that would
give us this form, y*u dot,
we need to just basically
identify that this is u dot.
And from previous
sessions, we saw
that this would give us
classical solution that
involves an exponential of the
integral of the right-hand side
after dividing by u,
which gives us exponential
of t squared over 2.
So integrating factor is
just using a trick so that we
simplify our left-hand side
and write it in the form
of the derivative
of the product, y*u.
So now, we identified
our integration factor.
It's u equals exponential
of t squared over 2.
Now, we can go back
to our equation.
And I'm going to just
label it with a star here.
So now, this equation
is written in this form.
t.
and the integral of just
basically derivative, just
itself.
So if we use first the approach
of definite integrals--
actually, we're going
to switch the order,
and I'm going to start with
indefinite integrals first.
So using indefinite
integrals, we'll
be integrating both sides.
And on the left-hand side, we
would just be left with y*u,
remembering that u is just
exponential of t squared over
2.
On the right-hand
side, we're just
integrating t exponential
of t squared over 2.
And here, you can recognize that
the derivative of exponential
of t squared over 2 would
have a t in front of it.
So this is actually a
very simple integration.
But we are in the case of
a differential equation
where we need a
constant of integration.
And again, here, we would
end up with two constants
of integration on both sides.
But given that we are dealing
with a first-order differential
equation, we can regroup
that in one constant.
And then, we can just
find our solution
by dividing this equation by u.
And u, if you remember, is
just exponential of t squared
over 2, so it's
equivalent to multiplying
both sides by exponential
of minus t squared over 2.
So I'm just going
to write it down.
Then, it just gives
us exponential minus t
squared over 2 multiplied by
exponential t squared over 2,
which is 1 and c exponential
of minus t squared over 2.
So that's our solution.
But remember that we're trying
to solve an initial value
problem they subject to
an initial condition.
And our initial
condition is y of 0
equals to 3, which
means that here, y of 0
would give us exponential to
0, which is just a constant.
So we end up with 3
equals to 1 plus c.
Therefore, c is equal to 2.
And the final form
of the solution
would just be 1
plus 2 exponential
of minus t squared over 2.
So we started with the
indefinite integral.
So what if we would do this
using definite integrals?
So we don't need to
start from the beginning.
We just need to take the
problem a few steps before
when we integrated both
sides of the equation.
And here, specify the
bounds of the integral.
So how do we want to specify
the bounds of the integral?
We're given an initial condition
that is at t equals to 0.
So that's what we want here.
And we're integrating
to the variable t.
But one thing is
important when you
do that is that you have
the variable t that is
in the bounds of the integral.
So we want the
integrand to not be
written in terms of the
variable of integration.
So it is very
important to change
the label of your
variables in the integrand.
That's how you proceed
for different integrals.
So in this case then,
we end up with similar--
so u dot y evaluated at t
minus u dot y evaluated at 0.
And from our initial
conditions and the form of u,
we know the value of this side,
of this term in the equation.
And here, we're just
again recognizing
that this is just the derivative
of exponential to s squared
over 2 evaluated
between 0 and t.
So here, if I just carry
on with the right-hand side
and then go back to left-hand
side in the next step,
we would end up here with
just t squared over 2 minus 1.
Exponential of 0 is 1.
And now, let's deal with
this left-hand side.
So again, we end up with u*y
minus u dot y evaluated at 0.
However, u of 0 is
just the function
exponential to t squared over
2 evaluated at 0, which is 1.
And y of 0, we have it because
that was our initial condition,
and this is only 3.
So we have u*y minus 1 dot 3,
which is just basically minus
3.
And on the right-hand
side, we have exponential
of t squared over 2 minus 1,
which gives us exponential
of t squared over 2 minus 1.
Now bring in this minus
3 on the other side,
you now have a plus 3,
all of this multiplied
by 1 over u, which was our
exponential of minus t squared
over 2.
And therefore, we end up
with a similar solution
that we had for the indefinite
integral, 3 minus 1 is just 2.
So we have minus t
squared over 2 plus 1.
So using both the definite
integrals approach
and the indefinite integrals,
we recover the same results.
And the main point
of this problem
was really to practice
using the integration factor
and practice using
both approaches
with the definite and
indefinite integrals.
So this ends the problem.
And I'll see you next time.